hello and welcome to the agenda
three belarussian political prisoners a
pakistani schoolgirl and whistleblower
edward snowden were unveiled as a
finalist for this year's sakura prize
who will be the victor find out on
thursday when parliament unveiled its
2013 laureate for the prize ceremony to
follow in november
after much delay a package of
anti-smoking laws will finally face the
music at the plenary the tobacco
products directive is tough proposals
include a health warning covering 75
percent of packaging and a ban on slim
and flavored cigarettes find out what
happens at the vote on tuesday
free movement in europe needs a better
protection of our borders so says the
mep who drafted the legislation into an
eu-wide surveillance program illegal
immigration is europe's big headache but
what's the cure drone technology what
length will europe go to protect its
fortress if approved the plenary euro
sir could be up and running by the end
of this year
can an eu professional card get more of
us living and working in other
neighboring eu countries that's one of
the ideas behind getting professional
qualifications recognized across europe
to increase mobility
the vote is set for wednesday
and a quick mention of an upcoming event
at a time when youth and employment is
at its highest the strasbourg parliament
will open its doors to thousands of
young people to share ideas on shaping
the future the youth event will be
officially unveiled by president schultz
on tuesday
and that's all we have for this agenda
take care and enjoy the week